der sandsturm godzilla fegt seit ende
juni über die karibik und die usa hinweg
die riesige staubwolke hat inzwischen
über 8000 kilometer zurückgelegt sie
soll so dick sein wie noch nie und über
dieses phänomen möchte ich jetzt mit
wetterexperte dominik jung sprechen er
ist mir jetzt live zugeschaltet guten
tag dominik hallo
vielleicht kannst du uns erklären wie
kommt es überhaupt zu einem phänomen
auf der einen seite ist natürlich sehr
viel wind in die sahara notwendig ein
richtiger sturm der die ganzen staub und
sand partikel in die atmosphäre
beförderten die ganz obere weitere
atmosphäre ganz weit oben in mehrere
kilometer und dann gerät ist dort war
sie in die strömung und deep lässt das
ganze zeug dann auch wirklich über den
atlantik und in diesen massen hat man
das eigentlich selten zuvor gesehen
und dieser staub ist mittlerweile über
der karibik angekommen das war schon vor
zwei wochen und hat auch die usa
erreicht also sahara staub rieselt jetzt
quasi in den usa herunter und das ist
wirklich schon eine recht große strecke
zurückgelegt worden ist und wie lange
wird der sturm anhalten was sagen die
prognosen also dieser transport an
saharastaub der wird wahrscheinlich noch
mehrere tage andauern es gibt noch eine
aktuelle prognose und die zeigt auch
sehr schön wie sie staubfahne weiterhin
von der sahara heute auch bis in die usa
erreicht und das auch in den kommenden
drei bis vier tagen mindestens noch also
der nachschub reißt einfach nicht ab da
kommt man wieder neuer sand und staub
hinterher und das ganze strömt munter
weiter in die usa und gerade in den usa
da gibt es aktuell auch eine markante
hitzewelle in texas und arizona hat
teilweise temperaturen 49 50 grad und
dann kommt cuba sí der sarah stock fast
schon richtig kann der gotteszeller
sturm denn auch zu uns nach europa
kommen ja also das ist momentan nicht
der fall da müsste erstmal die strömung
sich komplett ändern auf er südwestwind
hier bei uns wir haben am nächsten tag
schon wieder mehr nordwest luft vor
allen dingen mittwoch kommt aus island
die luft sehr kühle luftmassen schon
wieder regenwetter und damit dieser
staub wirbelt abtreten auch mal zu uns
kommt dann muss
sich die windströmung endermann sieht ja
sehr schön auf dem feld bild hier das
ganze geht einfach richtung westen und
eben nicht nach norden richtung europa